- Mainly just that
we educate them.
It's like, hey, you're
moving here for a reason.
Don't import your,
if you're leaving a state
for economic reasons
or political reasons,
you know, don't vote
the way you did there,
come to Florida and understand
that policies matter,
the positions matter, the
reasons why we do things.
I served six years in the
legislature before this role.
I mean the policy
really does matter.
And so all those things,
the reasons you're moving here,
there's reasons behind why
we're the success that we are.
(ominous music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today is
the Secretary of State
of the free state of Florida.
Did you know I like Florida?
Cord Byrd,
welcome to The Rubin Report.
- Well, it's great
to be with you, Dave,
thanks for having me.
- Secretary, I'm
glad to have you.
You know, I suppose this show
has become kind of a
beacon on the internet
of the freedom that we're
exporting from Florida.
So I thought we could just dive
into kind of all the things
that we're doing
right here in Florida.
Will that be okay with you?
- That'd be perfect.
I'd love to talk about all
the things that we're doing
in the free state of Florida.
- Great.
So look, everybody knows,
obviously Governor
DeSantis and the blueprint,
we talk about it a lot here
that he's trying
to kind of export
to some of the other states
and they understand
what the chief executive
as the governor does.
But what actually,
let's do a little 101,
what actually does the
Secretary of State do?
- Sure, so I have an
appointed position,
which is a little different.
Most secretaries of
state are elected.
Florida had an elected
secretary until 2002.
Katherine Harris of Bush V.
Gore fame was our last elected.
Since then, it's been
an appointed position.
So I'm the state's
Chief Elections Officer,
the state's Chief
Protocol Officer.
So I interact with
foreign governments,
state's chief arts and cultural
officer, historical officer,
we have the division
of library resources
in the Department of State
and the division
of corporations.
So Sunbiz, you wanna start
a business in Florida,
you come through me
so I wear many hats.
- So let's talk about
the election stuff first
because when I voted
just a couple months back
obviously in the midterms,
in the gubernatorial
election here,
having it been my first
election in Florida,
I can't tell you how
thrilled I was to show my ID,
to sign something, to
walk over with a volunteer
who clearly showed
me where I was going,
a piece of paper,
dropping it in a box,
it felt legit and real
and that was in complete stark
contrast to what was going on
when I was voting
for several years
in Los Angeles, California.
What have you guys done
to tighten up the
election situation here
and is it basically
airtight at this point?
- Sure, well, I appreciate
the opportunity.
So I'll give you a
little bit of history.
So I actually started
as a young attorney
poll watcher in 1998.
I was in Palm Beach County
for Bush V. Gore in 2000,
and did some legal
work behind the scenes.
I spent 12 hours that
day watching people vote
and listening to people
openly joke about,
I voted in New York,
I voted in New Jersey,
hahaha, I'm voting again here.
So we've come a long way
some when we were Flori-duh
and everybody thought we
were terrible at voting,
there was really
only two counties
to where we are today,
which is the gold standard,
and that's because
the legislature,
the last two
legislative sessions
and under Governor
DeSantis' leadership
has continuously worked to
improve our elections process
to the point where, as you
just described, it looks easy,
but it's because we are
doing this 24/7, 365,
we're always working
on our elections.
- When you're talking to
counterparts in other states
that it's not going
as well, I'm not,
I'm not talking about
crazy California,
but even a more moderate state,
someone that either is a
Secretary of State there
or is involved in the election
process, are they jealous?
Are they asking you for tips?
I mean, it seems like our,
you know, we have a
presidential election coming
and I think we're gonna
see all of the craziness
or questions that
we had last time,
it doesn't seem like most of
the states have done anything.
- Right, and you mentioned
the Governor's blueprint,
and we are constantly
talking to other states,
and I was thrilled,
last week, I had a
representative from Wisconsin
come down on his own dime
to meet with us and says,
"I want to take back
to Wisconsin what
you are doing here.
You know, teach us, show
us what you're doing."
So I'm always
preaching the gospel
about what we're doing
and why it works,
and there's no reason why
other states can't
adopt the Florida model.
- Yeah, so speaking
of the Florida model,
I mean we can just go through
some of the greatest hits here,
but I'm curious, as you've seen
this mass influx of people,
last I checked, it was
about 1,200 people a day,
I think almost a million
people in three years,
I've asked the governor this,
but what challenges does
that present for the state?
- Mainly just that
we educate them.
It's like, hey, you're
moving here for a reason.
If you're leaving a state
for economic reasons
or political reasons,
don't vote the
way you did there,
come to Florida and understand
that policies matter,
the positions matter, the
reasons why we do things.
I served six years in the
legislature before this role.
I mean, the policy
really does matter.
And so all those things,
the reasons you're moving here,
there's reasons behind why
we're the success that we are.
- Yeah.
Are you guys shocked
at how well it seems to
be working at the moment?
I mean, obviously there's a
super majority in the house
and the governor's feeling
good after the landslide,
but just that it really
is happening here.
I mean, building is happening
fast, we're fixing roads,
you know, the aftermath
of Hurricane Ian,
which watching the rebuild
has just been unbelievable.
- It is, it's exciting.
I'm a native Floridian
fifth generation,
so it's in my mind a historic
time to be living in Florida.
And when I talk to
foreign governments,
I mean, if we were
our own country,
we'd be the 16th largest
economy in the world.
And foreign governments are
excited to come to Florida,
you know, with Miami being
the gateway to Latin America,
there's just so many reasons
why there's energy in Florida,
you know, from the
governor on down,
you know, great weather, you
know, great natural resources,
lots of fun things to
do, diverse culture,
and it is an exciting time.
- So when you see the governor
getting into it with Disney
and the nonsensical
"don't say gay" HB 1557,
how does that affect
what you're doing as
Secretary of State?
Does it affect what
you're doing at all?
- It really doesn't
affect me much.
I mean, I went from
a policy making role
to a policy implementing role.
Just yesterday, we rolled
out another elections bill,
which had its first hearing
in the Florida Senate,
so I am engaged on
elections law still.
But as far as what the
legislature's doing,
what the governor's doing,
it really doesn't
impact us all that much,
but certainly supportive
and voted for those measures
when I was in the house.
- Is anything not working here?
When I had Governor DeSantis on
last time just a couple
weeks ago, I said,
"Look, I gotta ask
you one tough one."
And the one tough
one seems to be,
you know, something
related to house prices
just because of the
influx of people.
But as you're looking at it
from another office altogether,
what are you seeing are the
struggles, are the issues,
the stuff that you
guys want to fix still?
- Sure, so I think that
it's a good problem to have,
that we have so many new
people moving to Florida,
but I think that
balance between growth
and preserving our
natural resources
and making sure
that we are mindful
of all the reasons that
we wanna live here,
from our beaches to our lakes
and rivers to water quality,
and that's been something that
the governor has championed.
And I think that's probably
our biggest challenge
but I don't think
it's a binary choice
where you can either have,
you know, growth and
terrible environment
or pristine environment
and five people live here.
And so I think that
is our challenge
moving forward as a state,
but we have the right people
working on those issues
and we'll make it work.
- I mentioned
Hurricane Ian earlier.
As you may or may not know,
my folks part-time are
down in Sanibel Island
and their place is still
in recovery at the moment.
What the job of the
Secretary of State
when a natural disaster
like this hits?
And how much coordination
do you do or try to do with
the federal government?
It sounds like
they were kind of,
they were kind of
good at the beginning,
maybe cut and ran
a little bit early,
but I don't wanna put
words in your mouth.
- Well, you know, that hit
right during the election cycle.
And so I immediately flew down,
or we went down there,
surveyed the damage,
met with the supervisors
of elections.
I mean, some of them, they
had their own homes damaged,
their staff damaged,
polling places destroyed.
And we wanted to make sure
that we could pull
off an election.
So I came back,
reported to the governor
what our findings are.
He stepped in, issued
an executive order,
we pulled off the election,
and the turnout
in those counties
was on par with everywhere
else in the state.
So it was so encouraging
when I went down there,
and people, even though their
homes had been devastated,
they wanted to vote and they did
and we're very proud of that.
So we know how to step up
during a natural disaster
and still preserve the republic.
- You know, one
thing that happened
or I guess didn't happen
during Hurricane
Ian or the aftermath
was that there was no looting.
You know there was
such an opportunity
for looting and crime
and all kinds of bad stuff,
and there was none of it here
and that really does speak
to the culture of
people here in Florida.
- Well, it is.
I mean, the governor, you know,
we're a law and order state,
the law means something.
And this goes back
to the election code.
And for so long,
for whatever reason,
people think, ah,
it's elections, law
doesn't really matter,
it's not enforced,
it's a wink and a nod,
it's okay if you vote twice,
nobody's gonna catch you.
Governor said, no,
we're creating an office
of election crimes and security,
we're gonna enforce
our election code.
And I think that only does
that deter the bad actors,
but it gives confidence
to the law abiding citizen
that their vote's gonna count.
So whether it's election law,
whether it's our enforcing
our criminal laws,
there is a clear
message in Florida
that our laws mean something,
they're gonna be enforced
and don't break 'em or there
are gonna be consequences.
- Staying on the election
thing for just a second,
I know we jumped off there,
but just jumping back
on that a second,
so in states that
are Democrat run
that clearly don't want some
of these policies put in place,
what would you say
to just the Republican
citizen who is there
related to what they can do?
I know we talked about what
maybe another Secretary of State
that's a friendly can do.
- Right, well, the governor
has said, in states,
you have to use the laws
that are in your state
and fight fire with fire.
So, you know, we're
against ballot harvesting,
we've made that
illegal in Florida,
but if ballot harvesting
is illegal in your state,
then you have to use
the law where you are
because unless you get into
the positions of power,
whether it's governor or
Supreme Court or legislature,
you're not gonna be able
to effectuate the chain.
So I would encourage
those individuals,
get involved, stay involved.
We look at what
happened in Virginia,
Virginia's a blue state,
they elect Glenn
Youngkin because I
know many of the people
who got engaged and were
at the polling places,
and it's long, it's
boring work, I've done it,
but it is critical,
critical to winning
and that's what I
would tell them to do.
- Yeah, are you seeing
more and more parents
get involved in
education down here?
I mean it seems like that
really was the instigator.
I think I saw you speak
at one of the blueprint
events a couple months ago,
I know I did,
and that was about parents
just getting on school boards.
And the governor was
going around the room
and he seemed to
know every county,
what was happening in
every single election,
who was getting on, who the
superintendents were, et cetera.
- It's been great and
it's empowering parents.
The governor appointed my wife
to the State Board of Education,
and she is the
voice the parents.
I mean we're parents,
we have a young family
and it gives people
encouragement that
they have a voice,
that they're being listened to,
from the governor on down
to the local school boards,
that being a citizen,
and I always preach this,
being a citizen requires
active engagement.
It's not an activity
where you sit back and
wait for things to happen.
You gotta get your hands
dirty and get involved
and you have that
opportunity in Florida.
- Are you guys ever worried
that, you know, the more we
do it right here in Florida,
the more that that
focus turns to us
and that that
could be a problem?
You know that the federal
government basically
which is seemingly
screwing up so many things,
that at some point it's like
they keep looking to Florida
going, man, they're doing
basically the opposite of
everything we do, it's working.
We are still in
the United States
and that that's an issue there.
- Right, well,
we're gonna have three
statewide elections in 2024.
My mind is already there,
I'm already working on that.
I know we are going to get a
lot of attention in Florida
for a whole host of reasons.
But I always go back to it's
the genius of the founders
that they gave us a federal
system, meaning federalism,
where the states can be 50
laboratories of experiment.
We're showing what's
right about America.
I'll battle, compare
us to California
and New York and Illinois
any day of the week
and I think it gives
people in those states hope
that we're not
lost, we can do this
if the right people and the
right policies are put in place.
- Are you ever worried that
we could tip too far red?
Is there such a
thing as too far red?
I mean, we're
accomplishing an awful lot,
but you know, that there
would somehow be no balance?
I'm actually just
throwing it out there,
I probably don't sure
don't think so myself.
- I think a lot about that.
But I think that at some
point we're gonna have to,
you know, let blue
states be blue states
and red states be red states
and we're gonna have
to be okay with that.
And, you know, the Supreme
Court said that in Dobbs,
I mean, listen, abortion's
not a federal issue,
it's a state issue,
but that means states are
gonna do things differently
and then people are gonna
vote with their feet.
You've said 1,200 a day
are moving to Florida.
And I tell people,
it's like they're
voting with their feet.
They're moving here
and that is an expression
of their opinion.
We're gaining people, the
blue states are losing people.
So I think that's an
encouraging sign that we still,
and that's a pressure valve,
it keeps things from getting
too far into crazy land.
- So I think when people
think of Florida, they think,
okay, we're leading,
obviously we led on fighting
COVID lockdowns and mandates
and that sort of insanity.
I think they see we're
leading on education,
which now seems to be
exported to Iowa and Arkansas
and some of these other states.
What else do you think we're
leading on at the moment
when the governor talks
about that blueprint?
- Oh yeah, just on
economic policies.
I mean our new
business startups,
I mean we can hardly keep up
with all of the new business
startups in Florida.
We're leading,
I mean, the governor just
signed a constitutional carry,
so we became the 26th
state to do that.
And my background
is as a second amendment
and firearms law attorney,
that's what I did.
On so many issues of freedom,
so whether it's elections,
whether it's business startups,
education, we really are,
we're leading on just
about everything.
- Yeah, it's
interesting too because,
you know, I'm down here in Miami
where obviously
it's growing so fast
and we're kind of
running outta room here,
but you know, when I've flown up
to Tallahassee a couple times,
you realize there's
actually plenty of room
to still build in Florida.
I mean we've got a lot of
land that I think can be,
bring in some new people
and start building
some new communities.
- We do.
So when I was in the
legislature, I represented,
I'm from the Jacksonville
area and Nassau County,
the furthest northeast
part of the state,
and there's lots of
land and it's growing
and that brings challenges,
some of the people that
have been there a while,
you know, they don't always
like all the new growth,
but there is plenty of
land, plenty of room to grow
and we just have to do it smart.
You know, smart growth
is a good thing.
Actually, I grew up in Miami,
so I've seen the changes there
from the seventies
and eighties to today
and it's a wonderful place,
but you are kind of constricted
between the coast
and the Everglades.
But there's plenty
of places in Florida
we have room to grow.
- You know, the governor has
been obviously talking a lot
about ESG and figuring out a way
that we can have some of our,
the state's money less
invested with these companies
that are focused on
diversity, equity, inclusion.
Does that involve any of
your day-to-day operations?
- It really doesn't.
We're ministerial when it comes
to starting new businesses.
I mean, if they file the
right paperwork, they do that,
so the CFO's office,
Jimmy Patronus,
the ESG stuff mainly comes more
through the chief
financial officer.
But certainly, you know,
whether it's the legislature
having the power of the purse,
whether it's the
universities and saying,
no, listen, we're
spending taxpayer dollars,
we call the shots, you
don't make the policies,
or whether it's ESG
in corporations,
we do have the power of the
purse and we're exercising it.
- So one of the things we
talk about on the show a lot
is that there seems to be
this kind of divergence
amongst Republicans right now,
like either we will just be
small government Republicans
and never use the levers of
government to do anything
or as I think we're doing
it more so in Florida,
we'd prefer not to use the
government all the time,
but we're gonna figure
out the moments to do so.
Do you guys talk about that,
like when we can just
kind of let things be
versus those moments that we
actually do have to fight back?
I would say, you know,
going after Disney
might be one of those moments.
- Sure, no.
I would always
talk about the why.
Why are we doing certain things?
We don't legislate in a vacuum.
It all starts from the
foundation of the Constitution
and all of our powers and
authority of the government
and the laws flow from that.
So if we are operating within
those constitutional bounds,
then the government
has the authority.
I mean, the founders talked
about ordered liberty.
Well order requires some
form of agreed upon standards
that the community, a state
is going to live under.
And so I don't think it's,
you know, the small government
necessarily hard
libertarian view
that the government can never
be involved in anything,
that's just, you're just ceding
the power to your opponents.
- Are you shocked
when you see some of the
mainstream media reaction
to what's going on in Florida?
I mean, I basically, I'm
covering it every day,
and the things they
say about the governor
and about Florida and
what's going on here,
you know, that we're
this racist, homophobic,
backwards state,
and it's like everyone
that's in this room
with me right now,
these are all Cali transplants.
I spend so much time every day
saying hi to people at stores
who are just moving here,
everybody's happy
and free and smiley.
I go to New York,
everybody looks miserable.
I was in DC last week,
I mean, everybody's just had it.
And here, it's just
smiles and sunshine.
- It is, it's different.
It is amazing When I read
what's in the mainstream media.
I mean when I read
about things that,
the words they put in my mouth,
things that I've never said,
they don't listen.
We put out press
releases all the time
about people registering
to vote and get in,
you know, get engaged,
make sure all of your
information is up to date
and all I do is get called
a voter suppressionist
and all we're trying to do
is prevent certain types
of people from voting.
So it's a little frustrating
but it's the
environment we live in
and I just always point back to,
if we're putting points on
the board for the people,
they will be our
best messengers.
And like you said, people
are happy, they're smiling,
the state is growing and
the proof is in the pudding.
- You mentioned the
concealed carry,
so that just went
into effect I think
was that yesterday
literally or just?
- So it was passed,
the governor signed
it into law on Monday,
I believe it goes
into effect July 1.
- July 1st, okay so,
in essence, this is
just permitless carry.
Is that really what
the fight was about,
whether there should
be permits or not,
as opposed to the concealed
carry in and of itself?
- Correct.
So since the mid-'80s,
the law in Florida was that
you had to have a permit,
a license from the state,
in order to carry a concealed
firearm outside of the home.
And the decision was made.
and I agree with it 100%.
You shouldn't need a permission
slip from the government
to exercise a
constitutional right.
And I would always
tell my colleagues,
the bad guys don't
follow the law anyway.
Criminals by definition
don't follow the law,
so all we were doing was
burdening law-abiding citizens,
and now we've given
them that opportunity
to defend themselves when
they're outside the home
without a permission
slip from the government.
- Speaking of
defending themselves,
you know, obviously having
in the last two weeks
this shooting in Tennessee
and there have been
over the course of years
a few shootings,
obviously the Orlando
Pulse nightclub one
and the Parkland
outside of Orlando
shooting at the school there.
What are we doing
in terms of that?
What can the state do?
Is that up to the cities?
Who decides what's happening
in terms of security of schools?
- Sure.
So in Florida, we have a
very robust preemption law.
So all firearms regulations
are at the state level,
there's none at the local level.
So after the Parkland shooting,
the state stepped up
and appropriated millions of
dollars for school security
and have put in
robust enhancements.
That's happening
at the state level,
they're very aggressive
to ensure that our
schools are secure.
I have an eight
year old daughter.
I mean I think about
this every single day,
but when you live in a
constitutional republic,
you have to balance
constitutional rights
with liberty and freedom
and safety and security.
And listen, you put
everybody in prison,
we can have the safest
country in the world,
but that's not, it's not
the road we're going down,
and every one of these is
tragic, but what I look at is,
it's not the guns,
the guns have been
prevalent in America,
you used to be able to order
guns through the Sears catalog,
you can't do that anymore.
So there's something
fundamentally wrong
with our culture,
and that's where we need to
be focusing on and fixing
and mental health
and we're doing all of
those things in Florida.
- Yeah, are are we
doing anything on the
mental health side?
You know, I'm
always kind of like,
when I go to back to Cali, you
know, you go to Los Angeles,
every other billboard is for
California mental health,
this or that and it
always seems sorta,
I mean it seems
darkly humorous to me,
like as if the
state of California
is gonna be able to help
anyone's mental health,
but what do you think the
role of the state is for that?
- Right, I mean,
we should have resources
available for people,
we shouldn't stigmatize it.
We should make people say,
if you have are having an
issue, they should seek help
and we should help
where we need to.
I mean, if people need
financial resources,
the state should step up.
But I think it goes back to too,
you know, the way we
raise our children.
And my parents taught
me at an early age,
life isn't fair,
deal with it early
and we're so
protecting our children
that we're insulating them
from any type of misfortune
when they're children,
so they haven't learned
the coping skills.
And so when you become an
adult and life gets really hard
and you've never been
told no in your life
or had to deal
with any adversity,
I can understand
why people break,
but I don't know that
government can fix parenting
other than emphasizing
and fostering a state
and an environment
that we emphasize the role
of parenting and families
and their nurturing role
in preparing young people
to become citizens.
- Is there anything else
we should cover here?
You know, I keep
saying the main thing
that I think Florida
is exporting right
now is competency,
that it just,
it feels like we have the
right people in charge
who are balancing that blend
of when you use the
government, when you don't,
how you actually spend properly,
where you wanna apply
the law, et cetera,
and that's just kinda working.
So did I miss anything here?
- No and I'm glad you raised
the point of competency
because I think what I see in DC
and there's a lot of people
who get into politics,
it's just celebrity
by another means.
And they think it's about
tweeting and getting on TV,
but actually the day-to-day,
the mundane job of actually
government governing
and making sure that our
elections are working,
that you can go
file a corporation,
that takes work, it
takes competency.
I have an amazing
staff of people
who come to work
every single day,
some of those nameless,
faceless bureaucrats
that we talk about,
but they do a wonderful job.
And that's what I would
emphasize and to your point,
that competency matters
and I think governor's
talked about that,
that he puts people in
place that he can trust
to go run an agency and make
sure that we're delivering
for the people of
Florida every single day.
And if we're not doing that,
he's gonna take us out,
you know, he's gonna remove
us and put somebody in who can
and I think that's a
testament to his leadership.
- Secretary,
probably not the most difficult
interview you ever did,
but I'm just happy
to amplify all the
goodness out of Florida
because it literally
changed my life
so appreciate your time.
- Like I said, I'm a huge fan
and it's been an
honor to be with you.
Thank you, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our Politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our Full Episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.